here at home non-profits across the  valley are ramping up efforts to provide  services to those in need  the local orcas organization reach along  with walgreens and all saints episcopal  church  partnered up to provide food and free  flu shots ahead of the thanksgiving  holiday  more than 100 turkeys were also given  away  a lot of families that they have lost  their jobs they  they are undocumented and they are not  they don't have access  to a lot of programs and they also lost  a loved one  they have people sick they are  hospitalized they cannot visit  the non-profit reach will host another  flu shot event on monday from 10 a.m to  1 p.m  we have more information on our website  eight newsnow dot com